Donald Trump's Jewish allies are begging
him begging him to condemn Kanye West
and Trump is reportedly refusing there's
a very good article in Rolling Stone
Trump's Jewish allies are begging him to
condemn Kanye he's refusing prominent
Jewish and human rights leaders are
circulating a letter asking the former
president to distance himself from Kanye
West and Nick Fuentes they were the
people that had the the dinner with
Trump the other day a trump advisor
responds I've seen it and I do not care
I encourage you to read the entire
article there's a couple different
things that are important to talk about
here number one it is appalling
appalling that Trump still has Jewish
friends that in and of itself doesn't
make any sense whatsoever oh but David
sir the uh his his daughter converted to
Judaism and his grandkids none of that
this is not about that it's not even
really about Trump's personal beliefs
about Jews although sure I mean I think
we kind of have a sense of what they are
but it's about
the factions that Trump gives
credibility to by not denouncing or
condemning now to really understand a
lot of the entire Jewish Republican
thing this is as good an opportunity as
any to remind folks in the audience that
support for Israel
in the vague way that Evangelical
Christians quote support Israel and
support for American Jews could not
possibly be more dramatically different
things okay right wing support for
Israel is primarily based in
evangelicals who believe for biblical
reasons that Jews running Israel is a
step towards the return of Jesus Christ
now I know some of you will say and I'm
realizing I don't have my headphone on
and I'm going to need it for the next
segment I'm just going to put it on
while we chat there are people who will
say oh but David these folks love Israel
they just they love love Israel they
love it not because of any concern for
anti-Semitism or anti-jewish
discrimination or whatever the case may
be they love it because they see it as a
path to the bringing back Jesus that's
what it is American Jews have completely
different beliefs and ideas etc etc and
just because you see a right winger a
Republican cow Towing to Israel in the
particular sense that Evangelical
Christians like it doesn't mean that
they are supportive of American Jews or
for even understand never mind are going
to fight against anti-Semitism so that's
number one
unfortunately some Republican Jews
ignore that
and they throw in support with
Republican candidates fortunately It's
relatively few because American Jews are
one of the most left-wing voting blocs
in the country uh American Jews black
folks two of the most left-wing voting
groups Trump also has black allies right
so it's not completely uh incredible
that he is Jewish allies as well even
though if even though it doesn't really
make any sense based on policy but the
most important aspect of this to
understand is Trump sees people
as objects tools or a means to an end
and we saw when those folks are no
longer useful to him he dumps them
flushes them 10 to 15 times and
unfortunately there are certain people
that don't get this and they get tricked
and we're seeing it now once again with
Jewish voters but it seems this may be
the end of the line for Trump's Jewish
supporters we'll see there will always
be some
You Love non-fiction books you love
learning as much as you can about
politics and economics and history and
science but you just don't have the time
to read every book that you want to read
that's why I'm such a big fan of
blinkist it's the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
them down into an explainer that you can
read or listen to in 15 minutes and get
the most important insights from the
book you take a topic you've been
wanting to explore and you can consume
10 books about it in an afternoon it
gives you a meaningful overview and
insight into what other books you might
want to read in full I just read welcome
to the universe it's Neil deGrasse
Tyson's latest book that's exactly the
type of book that I would love to have
the time to read but my stack of books
is already so big my girlfriend and I
also use the blinkist connect feature to
share and discuss books with one another
with one account and it makes a great
eight last minute holiday gift you can
try blinkist free for seven days and get
25 off a subscription at blinkist.com
packman the link is down below